P
ID. OTHE GUSTE UNCOVERING VICMS
IN SURFSIDE,DA. TTUAL SITE SELF.
ROSA, THIS IS THE TIME N  GETNSD
IT'S IDIE WHATE
SEEING.
PLEASEELL US.
>> Reporter: I WANT TO WARN R ED
AROUND THE COUNTRY K
OR HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS THAT E
D TO THIS AP
I JUSTT TON YO
THESE IM MT
FOR YOCH, BECAUSE THIS
ISIRST TIME
ACCESS TO THICOLLAPSED
AS YOU IMAGINE, YOU CA
FEEL T PAIN, YOU CANL THE GEY ME
FISPONDEE
SURROUNDING US. WHAT YOU'RE LOO
THAT HAPD TION
AT FRONT PORTI
OF THE BUILDINIS
THIS IS WHAT'S KNOWN AS TH
TH SD RESCUE ARE THED SEARCH
USING TO FIND SIGN TNDRS.
FI
RUBBLE, THEN YOU'LL SEY
CHINY .THOSE ARE THE TOOLS THAT
BEING USED RHT NOWCH
U N  THESERA
THEY HAVE AMERICAN FLAGS FLYINGK
THE SKY.
THEY ARE VERY CAREFULLY SIFTING
AVCH THE
IT'S SAFE.RST HAPPEN
THEYOME IN CONTACT
METHODICALLY THEIR
MENTS, BECAUSE ANY MEMULHIC.
NOW, TISEAH ASK
T
THAR
RESCUE
HAVE NOT GIVEN A T
E INTO A
RECOVERY PHASER FOCUS RIGHT IS A
TALKING TO ONE OF THE FAMILIES E
THE SITE JUSIES
E TO SEARCK OF THE EFFORTS THAU
SURVIVS.
RUG  EN 13 .USTHIS ONE MAN SAYS'
ARE FACING.CUE TEAMSEFFORTT PEAD
YOU CAN SEE THE THICCONCRE
THTANTOR OW
FAMILIES TO SE BEI
THEIR LOV
IMPORTANT FOR THEM T OF THE DAN
VISID THIS SITE,Y
WITNESSED ONOFERSONNEL
TUMBLE 25 FEET DOWN PI O
.
THOSE ARE MES  EXPOSINSELVES
OUEY ARE WKI 12-HO
OF THESMEN AN
TAS TOIREIR
TO MAK TT THEY'RE
IN THE PHYCAL CONDSSARY TO CONS
THAT SNYE  D KNOW PEOPLE WHOSS
THAT THEIR LOVED ONES COME OUT
OF COURSE, AS U LOT VA PEOPLE
INSIDE.
HO A MIRACLE, BUT YOU'RE
WAS T GRATELEAST 36 PEOPLERE O
HEAR ROSSARY
NOT TOY TO SPERATELY RA TIME.
THEY'RE ALSO RACING NO
ELHU LDIOR NOW TOGIST  HHOPE.S
THIS SEARCH AND YOU NOW HAVE THE
STORM.
TET ER
AND WHAT MAY G.
>> ERIET
OPERATION IN SURE.
IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE MAINLY
CLEA N CLEAR, BU
Y,OVER ITH
THEM.
THEY HAD THE WORST OF IT VE
E IN THE3 DAYS. MOMENTS AGO, AI
EXPANDING THIS AREA E W IGTOO
IS.
THAT MEANS IT'S GETTIN
STRONGER.
IT'SELY BECOMEA CATEURRICANE LA
E LANDFALLTHE BIG BEAREA.RNING
OR HEARD ANIAEL.CANE THREE YEAR
2019.
LAIG THEO 29
FEET.
I'M NC IN
LIVES IN TAMPA BAY AND SARASOTA,
STILL, IT'S GETTING
T MAKEITY TOWARD
BEN, THAT' PLACE BECAUSE
'STLUN GIVE YOA OFOW RAR
E A HURRE
LANDFALL IN JULY ON TH
136 BERE FLORIDA, THE
THEY WERE EVEN NAMED.